hello everyone and welcome to the
urbanist agenda the podcast where we
pull back the curtain to show you how
urbanist content creators plot and
scheme to make cities work better for
everyone I started this podcast because
every content creator I know has a long
list of ideas that they'd like to turn
into videos someday I know my list is
well over 200 long and new ideas and
topics are constantly coming in so I
wanted to have this opportunity to talk
to other YouTubers about what they're
thinking about what they've seen on
social media lately and discuss those
topics that are of interest to them but
aren't quite ready to be turned into
full-length videos we're going to try
releasing these podcasts about once a
month at first though the first two
episodes are available right now every
episode will be uploaded to nebula a few
days earlier so if you're not already a
nebulous subscriber you can sign up now
at
go.nebula.tv Agenda signing up at that
link also helps support this podcast
because believe it or not we're not
funded by some shadowy cabal online like
some of the people we're about to talk
about
I'll have a different co-host on every
episode and this time for the inaugural
episode I'll be talking to Adam from the
YouTube channel Adam something about a
topic that just won't go away the
conspiracy theories around 15-minute
cities
can you hear the face palm I'm making
right now so grab a cup of tea and get
ready for the unveiling of the urbanist
agenda
cue the sick intro tune
[Music]
hello everyone welcome back to the
urbanist agenda my name is Jason from
not just bikes and my co-host today is
Adam from Adam something Adam why don't
you go ahead and introduce yourself hi
I'm Adam something I do those videos on
that video site called YouTube indeed
yes I'm quite familiar with that video a
site called YouTube
So Adam
fantastic Channel I'm assuming that if
you're listening to this you've heard of
them already but if not check out Adam
something on YouTube he makes videos
about urban planning but also other
topics as well including leftist
politics he's talked about the war in
Ukraine he talks about topical things
more often than I do which is one of the
reasons I wanted to have them on here
today to talk about something that's
been topical lately at least over the
last few months
which is the conspiracy surrounding
15-minute cities this is one of these
things that I've watched happening and
just been shaking my head and I haven't
be really honest I haven't really wanted
to talk about it that much because it
just seems like a crazy guy screaming in
the corner and I'd rather talk about
more important things but
anyway that's where we are here any any
thoughts on that Adam yeah there's been
a different uptick regarding conspiracy
theories about 50-minute cities and
50-minute cities are now cultural war
and welcome to this culture war and
human Centric planning is also cultural
War yeah these cultural issues usually
come and go they're just used as a
cynical political ploy to gain outrage
this is usually done by Republican
parties but increasingly the global
reactionary for all right but my issue
though with the 15-minute City
conspiracy is that it is not going to go
away yeah that quickly in my opinion
because of certain money the interests
opposing 15-minute cities so the
conspiracy not to think that oh this is
the bridlerberg generally the Communists
and the Jews like you know no like the
big money interest is actually behind
the conspiracy nuts here so it's a
completely switched situation and this
is why I think it's not going to go away
this conspiracy anytime soon because
15-minute cities directly harm the pro
profit margins of these corporations and
interest groups who oppose 50-minute
Series so these would be for example
Excel mobile who keep funding you know
Fringe limited groups and also the Koch
brothers oil billionaires were actually
the one [__] brothers arriving at this
point oil billionaire who is also behind
prageru YouTube's massive right-wing
disinformation Channel yeah and you've
talked about prageru in the past I know
like years ago they made a war on Cars
video that good friends over at Burger
yes there was a bunch of nonsense I know
you made a video talking about that so
actually before we get too deep into it
I guess for people who maybe haven't
heard of this before or haven't heard of
the term before until this conspiracy
which I think is interesting I've
actually found there's been an interest
in what 15 minutes these actually are
since this happened because a lot of
people just hadn't heard about it before
but let me talk really briefly a
15-minute city is just a neighborhood
well sometimes called 15 minute
neighborhoods it's just a neighborhood
where you can get pretty much most the
things you need for daily life within 15
minute walk or cycle of your house
that's it it's really really not that
exciting I actually think 15 minutes
cities is kind of a silly term which is
why I've never used it on my channel
before I just I mean it's okay
A little bit catchy but I just I've
never felt the need to talk about it I
feel like just talking about the
walkable cities and mixed use walkable
neighborhoods is you know perfectly
reasonable thing to talk about but
anyway 15-minute cities is a bit of
branding it's funny to me because I the
only reason we need this term at all is
because we've been building our cities
incorrectly for so many years that we
now need to be reminded how to do it
properly it's kind of like traditional
development is another one yeah it's a
50-minute city or as we've known it
before World War II a city so you know
yeah right it's I think I've made the
joke in the traditional when talking
about traditional development it's what
we used to call the way you build things
like the way you used to build things
that's it it's literally just a normal
way of building a city so that you're
not car dependent the opposite of the
15-minute city is the card dependency
where you can't even feed yourself
without getting in a car which is crazy
but it exists all over the US and Canada
so the 15-minute cities thing the name
of it kind of it's been floating around
for a little while but it kind of
started with the changes that are
happening in Paris with uh the mayor and
edel go oh yes one of the people working
on her Administration came up with the
term in French of course about how she
wanted to improve Paris so that
everybody had what they needed within 15
minutes and the truth is this stuff has
been going on for years since about 2020
anyway it's been a relatively recent
thing the pandemic has woken people up
to the fact that their cities are better
when there are fewer cars thank you
China
we're mixing our conspiracies here Adam
and anyway this is not new in terms of
like an urban planning concept it's just
it's got a little bit of a shiny name to
it now yeah I mean it's a complete sort
of manufactured outrage around the name
50-minute cities I mean I think it's a
good catch alter like if you want to
explain it to someone like just you know
Uncle Joe who just wants to grill you
know what is this well it's a 50-minute
city you know like it's like oh okay so
that's that's sketchy that sounds nice
that's marketable which okay fine but uh
I mean the 15-minute City I mean I can
also see from a conspiracy notes
perspective how
the 15-minute City Eagle apart hide and
stuff like that I mean it also has
unfortunately Disturbed a lot of sort of
outrage conspiracy marketing potentials
kind of like how the vote counting
machines were operated by like Dominion
was the company's name right it's just a
company name whatever but like it the
name itself has of course massive
conspiracy not potential and I think
with the 15-minute city as well because
it's numbers it's scary like conspiracy
people find numbers generally scary
because you know numbers are communism
especially when they disagree with them
that is Jewish so I think this is just a
unhappy coincidence into which companies
like Exxon Mobil and interest groups
like you know the Koch brothers Coke
brother singular and other climate
change deniers Etc just like piled in
now that is of course a large number of
genuine crazy people who just think that
the Communists are out to get them the
user out to get them and the 50-minute
city is their latest tool to bring down
Western Civilization heterosexual white
males Etc but then again massive part of
this is just being astroturfed by Big
Money interests like the oil companies
because the 50-minute city cuts into the
bottom line of these giant corporations
yeah and this is the bottom line really
like this is why I think it will not go
away this conspiracy wave because these
corporations they are of course
incentivized to eliminate as many
threats to their profits as possible in
the 15-minute City currently is I would
say one of the most severe threat to
Giant oil corporations like big oil
let's go yeah well I think the thing is
I started my channel because we moved to
the Netherlands and it was basically an
explanation of why we gave up on North
America and why we wanted to live in the
Netherlands and ultimately the reason
was because we have a better quality of
life here and so you think here is
moving from a place that should be if
you listen to the car industry
propaganda it should be Utopia right
like my hometown should be Utopia
everyone has a car everyone has multiple
cars everyone can drive everywhere they
want they never need to get cold or wet
or or anything else and it's going to be
this wonderful place but the truth of
the matter is it actually kind of sucks
to sit in traffic all the time it really
sucks to not be able to like literally
not be able to feed yourself without
getting in a motor vehicle like you need
two tons of steel to feed yourself it's
ridiculous love to have my life behind a
paywall exactly that's exactly right I
think that's exactly the right term it's
like having your life behind a paywall
whereas when we discover that we could
live somewhere where we can literally do
whatever we want with a short walk or
maybe a bike ride anything farther we
can hop on a train or a tram or
something and we can even get a car if
we want to I mean it's not like it's not
allowed it's just I don't drive very
often not because I don't like driving
not because I hate cars but just because
why would I it's way more convenient to
walk cycle or take public transit than
it is to have to get in a car and so the
fundamental thing with my channel is
that this way of living is better it's
better for a lot of people it's actually
better for most people I would argue
even the people who have to drive
because there's less traffic so this is
a better way of living
but it's inevitable that if everybody
lived this way you'll be a lot fewer
cars sold and they'll be a lot less
gasoline sold and that's just fact oh
yeah oh yeah of course this is why
they're being funded by Big Oil but the
issue is I think there's a more
fundamental underlying issue here let me
just get out myself
I think that in our world currently is a
rage and this content is actually
exploding everywhere you understand and
I think this is part of the fact that
neoliberal capitalism is reaching its
limits you know so fantastic very old
are there thank you impression aside
yeah the underlying issue is that of
course there is discontent there is Rage
all around us there is you know people
are not really happy and they have good
reason not to be happy let's be clear
about that right yeah of course I mean
people are just not living as well as
they used to or as they were promised
and this is according to check which I
generally agree with is due to the fact
that our current system is reaching its
limits and the problem is we don't
really have an idea yet as to how we
should reform the our current new
liberal capitalism because Asia puts it
we have three solutions none of them
work Soviet socialism is gone it's dead
the Western welfare state is currently
dying and the third option would be the
direct democracy people but it's also
not ideal it's also not good I think
because we Face Global problems so then
if you devolve power into the micro
level well then how are you going to
solve problems that affect the planet I
mean at that point you of course won't
and since we don't have any solutions to
the current issues we have no idea I
think puts it in a way that we are all
fukuiarized in a sense that we all
believe that history has ended that
neoliberal capitalism is the ultimate
system that we have and that there is
nothing Beyond this this is the Apex and
all we can do is just to make marginal
improvements yeah currently and this of
course is I mean this is not true and we
see that the current system is breaking
apart in front of us and this produces a
ton of discontent a ton of Rage some
four right populists like Trump Orban
Etc weapon all around the world
capitalize on and then these giant like
conspiracy industry complexes grow out
from the ground which then as we see now
Big Oil tends to direct their creative
energies into the right direction which
is to oppose 15-minute cities yeah well
the thing is Big Money interests are
always going to hold the power and they
have the most amount of sway but that's
very difficult to change I mean I guess
I would say to people who I mean look
there's some people who are just in the
deep end here but I would say to people
who are going towards this conspiracy
theory like we agree with you that there
are problems with the world there are a
lot of problems with the world but like
doing exactly what the fossil fuel
companies and the car industry wants you
to do is not the solution man some of
these people are being played like a
fiddle by these fossil fuel
organizations they really are oh yeah I
would say that yes there is actually a
conspiracy but the other way around you
see so you know if the people protesting
against Eco apartheid green communism
whatever I mean they are the ones who
are being funded by essentially a dark
money if someone is Keen towards this
conspiracy theory as well follow the
money right yeah always always follow
the money here in with 15-minute cities
who loses out who loses money well core
industry oil industry I don't think
there is even any malice behind them
doing this like you know funding
conspiracy groups and opposing these
things I don't think this is malice this
is just how the system works right this
is you know there's fiduciary
responsibility meaning that you know you
should always take steps which will make
the most money for your shareholders and
a version of this applies of course like
funding conspiracy groups is like it's
gray zone so there's no legal
requirement but of course these
corporations will do what will make them
the most money or that will safeguard
their profits and 50 minutes it is
already threat to their profits
therefore they will find any way
possible this is not just them funding
you know conspiracy networks this is
also them just paying up politicians or
stuff like that yeah like actually
currently in the Czech Republic there's
actually an interesting example
currently Czech Republic I mean the
Czech Republic is generally a I mean
it's a European country right I mean
cities are built how North American
cities should be built ideally right
that's pretty neat but District Republic
is strangely core-centric as a country
of course they have this gigantic core
well not gigantic but sizable car
manufacturer called which is now owned
by the Volkswagen Group by the way right
but also in Germany there's a huge
presence of the car industry and
interestingly enough in the Czech
Republic and in Germany real bike
friendly planning is surprisingly
difficult to achieve so the more sway
car industry hold in the country the
difficult it becomes suddenly and yeah
of course there's been this battle
recently that the so the mayor of Prague
is the ultimate Boomer like he is just
this 80 something year old decrepit like
you know overweight dude who takes his
score every day to work in the center of
Prague I think his promotional photo was
when he arrived to I think his first day
on the job as being a mayor he was
walking away from his car in in the
center of Prague and the car was like in
an area where he should not Park like in
front of a crosswalk where he's not
allowed so that's the attitude there's
currently a huge debate in Czech Society
in Prague mainly about well should we
live car free should prog have less cars
I mean if you know my content I would
say oh [__] yeah dude of course actually
I'm sorry I don't know if swearing is
allowed I think it's perfectly fine go
nuts all right so basically Prague is
overwhelmed by cars at this point like
that is true the historic Center Prague
one so-called is run by conservatives
and it is just a car Depot basically
there's cars everywhere in the beautiful
historic medieval city core even they
just like they're just the slot cars in
whatever they can and there's been this
increasing discussion among checks that
like maybe this is just not the best
thing right right and there's now every
week there is also the last generation
the I think that that's a group who
protests on progs sort of soviet-era
urban freeway the so-called magistrada
they block two lanes out of three and
they just like slowly walk across it
causing a traffic jam of course they are
protesting to Institute Universal 30
kilometers per hour right in Prague
which is I think is a very nice thing
that's something Amsterdam's doing
actually they're in the middle of
changing everything to 30 kilometers an
hour oh good Amsterdam is approximately
like 50 years ahead of Prague notice
that the Netherlands does not have a car
industry and I think the point that you
made there about the car industry having
an effect on these things is absolutely
correct and I don't think that's any
kind of conspiracy I think that's just
the natural result of having a car
industry because the thing is if you
have a car industry you're going to have
a bunch of people who work in that
industry or connected to that industry
right like for example I grew up in
Southwestern Ontario which has a huge
car industry there they make all sorts
of cars for American brands and even the
foreign brands for the North American
Market my aunts and uncles all worked at
GM or other companies connected to the
Auto industry my grandfather started his
own through Manufacturing Company
basically for making custom metal parts
and the vast majority of his customers
were car industry customers so you think
about someone even like my grandfather
who you would think he owned his own
company later on in his life he had
worked for a while and then started it
actually after he retired so he was
making like literally tool and die stuff
right so you would think okay well
that's not car industry but when he's
selling into the car industry is he
going to be in favor of cars the
industry doing okay well hell yeah he is
right and so I don't think like if my
grandfather if he were alive today
coming out and saying well you know I
don't know if it's such a good idea to
get rid of all these cars I mean that's
not a conspiracy that's just him looking
out for his own well-being right oh sure
yeah this is a very difficult situation
actually so you have to balance the
well-being of multiple groups who
sometimes overlap so basically your
grandfather or let's take me for example
if I started a tool and die company and
my family depends on being suppliers to
the local auto industry which in Hungary
there is a prepunders of by the way so
there's like a huge numbers of assembly
lines Etc I am Hungarian if anyone's
wondering I grew up in Hungary the
plants that are in Hungary represent the
very end of the production chain so it's
nothing big like if this is like being
assembled but people still depend on it
so the problem becomes people depend on
it for their livelihoods so their lives
will be measurably worse should those
car Industries scale back right A lot of
people will have a lot worse life but
then the consequences of the car
industry of what they create and how
they shape cities by proxy meaning just
by consequence of us planning around
cars that also makes life miserable for
a lot of people potentially even more
right and of course as you said there is
overlap there too people can be working
in the car industry and also be having
very negative effects even health
effects and things like that from Cars
oh yeah yeah so the problem becomes you
know which way are you going to go the
status goal is no longer sustainable and
we're gonna have to make some very
difficult choices I would say and very
soon actually what I increasingly making
it but I would say here I'm going to say
a swear word to uh do wrapping everybody
incoming yeah trigger warning foreign
yeah sorry for the drama no but I think
this is an instance where incrementalism
can actually work so if you do a gradual
phase out of course then if you leave
time for industry to reorient itself a
bit that can work of course this would
require like government intervention so
this would be called cohesive plan if
the government decides okay which I mean
let's be clear I'm Dreaming right now
like this is there are only Pro cycling
and proper experience Etc planning only
happens on these like local initiative
levels so unidago is doing a great job
in Paris it's excellent really I've been
there this year I've seen it for myself
it's awesome
you go outside of Paris to these suburbs
run by different people it's the same
old [__] so yeah and in fact Paris has
some stuff that if you change the brand
names you could think they were in the
U.S sorry not Paris France outside of
Paris yeah right these are still
happening on the local level which I
would think in an Ideal World you know
in a world where green Communists are on
the government we should ideally have
some sort of overarching plan like okay
these are our Target numbers for number
of vehicles on the road and models split
for those of you don't know model split
is what percentage of people use what to
get around so you know 20 cars 50 public
transportation Etc so we should have a
coherent plan which forecasts okay we're
gonna have this much going this way and
then we also project okay we have this
much manufacturing capacity and the
factories are set up to manufacture this
many cars right let me go okay let's sit
down with these manufacturers and be
like okay look this is how it's going to
be decongestion has wide public support
generally even in progress it turns out
even in Prague more than three quarters
of the population says that there are
too many cars there so this is a measure
with broad popular support so you're
going to have to shift your operations
to something else and this could be
something similar to what happens with
like you know these old coal mining
areas in Europe not in the UK but in the
rest of Europe where instead of just
like cutting it like goodbye noko
instead there is like programs okay
we're gonna phase out go we're gonna
have like a bunch of training programs
to like get miners into other like
factories for example this is by no
means you know learn to code like trying
to teach minister to code or something
just like jobs training program if they
want to get another like Hands-On blue
color profession then the state will of
course help them so I think in order to
ideally this should happen with
decongestion measures should be heavy
United broadly because this way we could
minimize societal friction and it will
provide less opportunity for say big oil
to AstroTurf these like discontented
groups because there will be less of
them essentially yeah yeah I mean
there's a whole other wider a political
issue here and I think it is interesting
I mean the thing is these protests are
very clearly being funded by fossil fuel
interests and if anybody thinks that
we're inventing conspiracies here I'll
put a link in the description but
there's a few articles there there was
one good investigation done by D smog
that shows that this stuff really is
coming straight out of the fossil fuel
Network here and the funny thing is like
I spend a little bit of time looking at
some of the Twitter accounts that were
pushing the 15 minutes cities conspiracy
and I looked at these accounts before
the 15-minute conspiracy was being
promoted and it's all climate denialism
it's entirely climate denialism all the
way down oh yeah and it's so incredibly
obvious that around the same time they
all started talking about 15-minute
cities all of these Twitter accounts and
I think look some of these yeah you can
say some of these are Bots and some of
these are sock puppet accounts and
everything else and some of these are
just people who are in that sphere right
and they're just they have issues with
their life maybe they have even lost
their job because of green initiatives
or whatever I don't know but there's
definitely a message that went out to
these people a few months ago and they
started talking about it and you see
there again I'll put some links in the
description but it's the Heartland
Institute and the other one is not our
future so not our future for example has
been talking about climate lockdowns
even before the pandemic they were
saying that climate lockdowns are coming
this is something they invented and
they've been talking about it they've
been finding any example they can as to
here's an example this is it this is
what we've been talking about for all
these years obviously the pandemic had
real lockdowns and that really really
rocketed them up in terms of their
visibility oh yeah but the 15-minute
cities was just the latest thing and you
can see it very clearly if you look even
just a little bit into the history of
this stuff they were saying oh this is a
climate lockdown and that's a climate
lockdown and look there's another
climate locked out look at all these
examples it's so obvious the wealthy
billionaires are coming down and they're
going to make us do this and that and
then one of them was and look at the
15-minute cities and that one just took
off I've seen people on my subreddit and
stuff like that saying oh this happened
because you know Oxford proposed this or
Edmonton proposed that or Canterbury
proposed this this has nothing to do
with any of those programs at all this
was just they were desperately trying to
find anything to hang their climate
locked down conspiracy on and the
15-minute cities was the one that took
off oh yeah in some sense well actually
I might need to break out my user
compression again in some sense in some
sense I believe the the conspiracy nuts
or tragically correct about
all right so but they didn't bring
zerjack on this podcast man not yet they
are actually tragically right about
something right so the big fear in this
conspiracy circles I found be expressed
very simply they are afraid of being put
in the Pod and being forced to eat the
bug right because they get in the body
debug right which is a valid concern but
that's not coming from the
environmentalists right of course they
will look at you know today I went to
the store and I saw like vegan salami ah
I I will not eat the bug [__] you okay
by the way vegan Salam is great like for
me tastes better than the real thing you
know what this is just like I was saying
that uh living in a walkable city is
better and that's going to be the real
fear to them I've been eating beyond
meat burgers and they're actually better
yeah they're oh yeah they don't sit like
a rock in my stomach like a greasy meat
Burger does and so now I've switched to
them not because of any sort of
environmental reason just because I
prefer the taste of them oh yeah I mean
yeah me too basically so I mean I'm
looking forward to when Beyond Burger is
culture War you know I I I'm sure Beyond
Burger well I guess it doesn't hit Full
Steam culture War yet yeah not the idea
I mean I mean you know Rupert murdoc
will get to it eventually don't worry so
correct in the sense that so the future
that they are afraid of looks like is
heading towards us but not from the side
that they think the left is trying to
actually counteract this though as I
said like we have no idea yet how
because there's no alternative as of yet
but the current direction that this sort
of late stage neoliberal capitalism is
mistaking
is essentially the getting the body
debug right so as the wealth
concentrates more and more 30 people
have less and less and meanwhile
corporations grow and consolidate and
exert their influence and power and we
end up in situations where through the
overwhelming power of these corporations
conglomerates Etc people just become
consumer units so if you look at the U.S
cities like they are extremely atomized
they live in these commercial suburbs
well in the middle class is being
destroyed in the United States basically
and they live in these sort of atomized
neighborhoods far from each other in
these like cardboard houses they have
their little metal boxes in front of
them you know that's the paywall access
right rest of the city which to me is
the real getting the body debug right in
terms of read the bug I mentioned this
in the video recently food deserts are a
thing in the U.S like some like 24
million people live in food deserts and
so the dystopian future that the
conspiracy people are afraid of Is
tragically already here more so in areas
where corporations are allowed to run a
mock essentially of course in Europe you
have more controls so European
leadership is less captured by
corporations it seems in general it
varies it's only captured by Qatar every
once in a while you know and like when
they fund some Italian politicians but
otherwise in the US this is actually
very clearly visible like in Europe if
you go to a city you still have
communities you still have these social
areas though in some places this is of
course eroding yeah not so many people
live in Prague anymore because it's all
Airbnb because it's worth it to rent
your house out as an Airbnb yeah and
everyone else just like gets tossed it
away and like gets like pushed out from
the center for the report and these new
satellite suburbs are being built though
on a very small scale so what urbanists
in the Czech Republic are mad about is
like two streets that have like a kind
of like a bad public transit connection
sort of so it's not like North America I
think that this guy I see this
discussion all the time where online
where Europeans will say you know my
place is just as car dependent as the US
is and then the Americans will come in
and say well do you have this and this
and this and they're like oh my God no
what are you talking about and no
they're really not but I think coming
back to the ear issue and the conspiracy
is that if this was really about control
then these people would be advocating
for Rural living with solar panels and
electric cars that were open sourced and
you know available to everyone to fix
and repair like that would be their
freedom to move wherever they want
without anybody telling them what to do
but clearly that's not what they're
proposing they're proposing more cars
and no EVs and all fossil fuel based
stuff I mean it's really really clear
that this is not at all about this
freedom of movement or being locked in
or anything and it's literally the
fossil fuel companies are playing these
people like a fiddle oh sure oh sure
it's also this idea interacting with
their brains the conspiracy people's
brains that you know cars equal Freedom
yeah but that comes from decades and
decades and Decades of marketing from
car companies oh yeah but like of course
the newer generation doesn't really
believe in this anymore but if you look
at they also can't afford cars right
yeah
right but if you look at those protests
I mean the average age is not in the 20s
or 30s or 40s or maybe not even in the
50s yeah so it's a bunch of like Maddie
Boomers essentially which I mean seeing
how Facebook rots the brains of my
grandparents generation I mean I'm not
surprised Facebook has been a just like
this festering Hive of the most insane
conspiracy [__] really for years now and
in a tragic sense just a loop in social
media companies to do the equation as
well I mean social media companies Revel
in right-wing conspiracy stuff because
well you know good news is no news
outrage get clicks yeah and thus at
Revenue so yeah and you know honestly I
don't even think that it's just limited
to right wing things I think honestly
when you look at the financial
motivations of social media companies
it's really just as many clicks and
outrage as possible people arguing about
literally anything in the comments
brings more people back to the site it
ticks up their numbers for daily active
users oh yeah sure so in some tragic
sense once again the evil corporate
establishment quote unquote seems to be
on the side of the conspiracy theorists
who claim to be against the corporate
control because I mean hey if you put on
Facebook a post about like okay so this
is the MRI vaccine this is how it does
and it's like a A4 page explains
everything that'll get like 12 likes and
with some comment of like hello Martha
how are the kids or something like that
but if you post the picture like I gave
copied 19 vaccine to my daughter and now
she her head exploded and the bill
durberg and ah like you know if you do
something like that that [__] will get
tens of millions of views go all around
the world the Wildfire gets translated
to other languages by people with
similar affinities abroad and this
actually happens a lot in Hungary that
like they take these American cultural
or [__] and they just trace it into
Hungarian and start running like
essentially Fox News this info in
Hungarian quote-unquote public media
yeah I've seen the same thing and then I
learned for what it's worth a few years
ago the leader of the far-right party
was calling his opponents Democrats like
it was a Democrat plan I'm like dude
this has nothing to do with anything to
do with Europe and the Netherlands the
Democrats is well there's the front no
no it was a terrible day it was The Fad
okay and he was you know calling people
Democrats which is obviously just it's
coming out of America and it's being
translated into Dutch we're seeing
exactly the same thing they talk about
woke here too like what does that even
mean it has literally no meaning anymore
especially when it's been morphed and
translated at everything else it's just
used as a pejorative yeah walk is it
just like a cat show they're like they
don't know how to define it like if you
ask someone to Define it like from their
Camp I mean their brain will explode but
generally evoke is a casualty room which
changes its meaning in the context so
you know when you say oh you know I've
seen a black person kissing a white
person on TV that's woke you know Vogue
defines the characterizes the opposition
to you know interracial relationships
basically if the slave owning sound will
be around today like they would call the
north woke they would call Abraham
Lincoln woke it's a term that's lost all
meaning and I find online when someone's
pressed to Define it they give a
different definition than everyone else
has ever given everyone has their own
individual definition but of course
that's the way these things work and I
think bringing it back to the conspiracy
here the 15-minute City's conspiracy
also doesn't mean anything one of the
things that I found interesting is it's
actually not tied at all to anything
related to the 15-minute cities
initiatives that's been done by any real
City anywhere ever like for example in
Oxford they were saying that the license
plate cameras were the things that were
the 15-minute City there was literally
nothing to do with 15-minute city that
was just a traffic control system it's
like a toll system to keep too much
traffic off the road in rush hour
nothing to do with 15-minute cities and
in fact it's something that's for
example oslo's done before in Canterbury
they said the 15-minute cities
initiative was not being able to drive
through the center of the city also
nothing to do with 15-minute cities
that's actually just putting the city
into quarters something that's been done
in groaning and hunt in Belgium growing
in the Netherlands stuff that's been
done all over the place nothing to do
with 15-minute cities so again it's just
a term that is being thrown onto
anything because this is not a coherent
Movement Like again I've seen people
saying oh you know the only reason
they're doing this is because they're
upset about this policy or they're upset
about that proposal has nothing to do
with this they are literally throwing a
term at everything and anything to see
what sticks oh yeah it's just like this
amorphous it all begins with a feeling
that like things are [__] right right
you know things are right away the vibe
check is off which they're correct
absolutely on that for reasons I've
detailed earlier and then this amorphous
aimless directionless rage just sort of
surfaces Whenever there is something
happening which they consider to be part
of this vaguely defined blob which is
coming for them which I think are also
detailed and sometimes this
directionless which is like a gazer
basically it's like just like coming up
sometimes corporations put a a
proverbial rig over it to direct the
energy towards something that they don't
like you know like you know the
15-minute City in this case because
because it cuts into the profit margin
so yeah I think congratulations Jason we
just solved conspiracy
this has been a very productive podcast
I feel like we defined it we haven't
solved anything but the thing is that it
is so frustrating I don't know about you
but I've been getting the wef chill
stuff in my comments for a couple of
years now where not cases come in and
they're like oh you're paid off by so
and so and it's someone different every
time man I wish I was paid off by one of
these guys wouldn't it be great to get
some of that billionaire funds I really
appreciate that but no sorry it's mostly
my patreons and a few sponsors that are
funding me I mean if you want real
Grassroots buy the people for the people
stuff I mean look on the left because on
the right it recently came out that for
example Stephen Crowder most likely
could never have his show be profitable
he could never make a living out of it
because he was just like funded by
right-wing billionaires essentially like
that's right he was like trying offering
to sell his company but then when people
actually looked into it it wasn't worth
anywhere close to what he was trying to
sell it for is that what it was what I'm
trying to do is the daily wire business
oh it's like right the daily word offer
team was like five million dollars
Stephen Crowder it's like
yeah because of course because he's
getting more money like this is like
conservative dark money right and I
think there's another YouTuber Felipe
DeFranco maybe like a big YouTuber
million plus subscribers just like
talking about current affairs Etc and
it's known that they reached out to him
at one point that like because he was
like this Centrist sort of like not left
or right right someone reached out to
him actually being hey
would you like to promote some of our
talking points their Library like
conservative right wingish here's a
bunch of money and he declined and it's
like [__] man where are those people
when I need them right like I know where
is George Soros like George is supposed
to be funding all this apparently
because he once gave a few thousand
dollars to the Democrats or something oh
yeah and like you're Hungarian shouldn't
uh George Soros be in a palace right now
yeah where's my service money you know
yeah but like a much further does in
Hungary is just like have these ngos
which try to make things better locally
like I know a guy who runs this like
Cooperative pub with his friends and the
premises are rented out to them from one
of these ngos which is also funded by
shoulders but like this is just this
completely innocuous [__] meanwhile
half the [__] right to England are
were over at like Epstein's Island
banging 12 year olds so you know I'm
being a bit hyperbolic but well I think
yes I think that's part of your Mo I
think there is a bit of projection going
on here because some of these not all
but some of these channels really
legitimately are being funded but
they're not art panels Stephen Crowder
he's got this beautiful set with the
really nice lighting and he's got a
whole bunch of guys on set all the time
and like it's clearly a high production
setup there and I'm like got a little
corner of my office here yeah a
microphone I look at this and I'm like
there's no way man like there's no way
that if you were being funded the way
I'm being funded with patreons and a
handful of sponsorships here and there
there's no way you'd be able to afford
that set with those people in that
lighting and everything else and yeah uh
I don't know anyway but all I'm saying
is where the hell is my money if I'm
supposedly this WF chill then Where's My
Money w e f yeah I know right I'm
looking forward to the George Soros
check I mean I've been waiting for it
forever it never came anyway so is there
anything else before we wrap up here
that you want to say on 15-minute cities
or anything else in this realm no I
think we've discussed pretty much all of
bits so 50 minute cities are nice in
some strategic sense 50 minutes is
already ultimate conservative position
because we're trying to return to Monkey
basically that like oh yeah the old ways
are in this case the correct way right
right so I reject this post-modernist
nonsense that our cities must be dotted
with parking lots and urban freeways and
I advocate for the return to True
tradition of predictively walkable
studies all right well thanks so much
Adam I'm just happy to live somewhere
where I can walk to what I need and
don't need a paywall to feed my family
so oh yeah thanks so much do you want to
promote yourself just before we go I'm
Jason from not just bikes check it out
by search and not just bikes on YouTube
uh Adam oh sure thank you for having me
on I am Adam something you can find me
on YouTube slash Adam something all
right great well thanks so much Adam and
we'll have you on again some time to
talk about something equally as
interesting hey looking forward to being
on the bicycle Jihad podcast next time
cheers
thank you
[Music]